neben unserer erde existiert
höchstwahrscheinlich auch an
zahlreichen völlig anderen orten leben
das war ja schon öfter thema bei uns
denn fest steht mittlerweile die
bausteine des lebens können fast
überall zusammenkommen warum die
theorie der sogenannten habitablen zone
jetzt also überholt ist und welche
erdrückenden indizien es mittlerweile
zu außerirdischen leben gibt jetzt für
euch zusammengefasst im krieg zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
die theorie dass das leben auf unserer
erde tatsächlich nur durch einen
einmaligen zufall entstanden sein
könnte wird immer unwahrscheinlicher
und die indizien dazu sind mittlerweile
erdrückend heißt aber auch die theorie
der sogenannten habitablen zonen ist
überholt variationen sind ja die
umlaufbahnen um sterne in denen leben
auf planeten prinzipiell möglich wäre
denn in diesen habitablen zonen wurde
die theorie kann wasser fließen und
wasser ist die grundvoraussetzung
überhaupt verleben also somit darf ein
planet nicht zu nah aber auch nicht zu
weit weg von seinem zentralgestirn sein
denn sowohl dicke gletscher als auch
extreme hitze machen leben dieser
theorie zufolge unmöglich aber wie
gesagt diese theorie wurde von dem us
astronom michael hardt vor 40 jahren
begründet seine theorie beruhte auf
computersimulationen und war
letztendlich ein gedankenexperiment nach
und nach machten forschungsteams
weltweit entdeckung die hartz these
wacken ließen jede einzelne entdeckung
für sich ist super spannend deswegen
jetzt hier für euch im schnelldurchlauf
die vier spannendsten indizien dafür
das leben außerhalb der erde sehr
wahrscheinlich ist platz vier leben in
extremen fangen wir bei unserer erde an
auch hier leben mikroorganismen in
extremen zb bei 122 grad celsius in
heißen quellen und auch das andere
extrem ist möglich selbst hunderte
meter unter dem antarktis gletschereis
ist leben möglich und es wird noch
krasser lange für nicht möglich
gehalten aber dennoch war auch im
havarierten kernreaktoren wie cherno
wurde zum beispiel wachsen pilze und das
verrückte daran die erde selbst hat im
laufe ihrer klimageschichte quasi immer
wieder selbst dafür gesorgt dass sie
weiter von leben gewohnt bleibt studien
aus den geowissenschaften zeigen
tatsächlich dass die erde in gewissem
maße ihre temperatur selbst regulieren
kann extrem kalten zeiten hat sie quasi
entgegengewirkt in den vulkanen
kohlendioxid ausgestoßen haben und sich
die erde dadurch wieder ein stück
weiter erwärmte bei anhaltender
trockenheit dagegen sank gestein weiter
ab und nahm damit co2 mit aus der
atmosphäre
die ließ die lufttemperatur dann sinken
als sie diese erkenntnis
vor knapp 25 jahren auf das weltall
projizierten waren sie vom ergebnis
selbst überrascht in unserem
sonnensystem sollte demnach bis zur
umlauf des mars leben möglich sein auch
wenn er selbst alles andere als
lebensfreundlich geht platz 3 entstand
leben auf der völlig überhitzten venus
die theorie zur habitablen zone
innerhalb des weltraums hielt sich wie
gesagt sehr lange aber mittlerweile ist
eigentlich klar das leben theoretisch
auch auf der völlig überhitzten -
entstanden sein könnte denn wer weiß
eventuell besaß sie in einem ganz
jungen zeitalter wasser das
mikroorganismen die grundlage zum leben
gab forscherinnen und forscher halten es
für möglich dass diese dann irgendwann
einmal bei einem meteoriteneinschlag ins
all geschleudert wurden und es wird noch
verrückter in anderen sonnensystemen
sind viele planeten viel näher
beieinander so dass so ein hinüber
wechseln von mikroorganismen durchaus
vorstellbar ist diese könnten dann in
nischen am rand der habitablen zone
überleben bis sich die bedingungen in
ihrer ursprünglichen zone verbessert
haben platz zwei leben auf supererden
die entdeckung der zahlreichen
exoplaneten hat wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler weltweit noch zu einer
weiteren erkenntnis kommen lassen
auch auf den sogenannten supererden ist
leben mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
möglich sie sind teilweise zehnmal
schwerer als die erde selbst als sie
entstanden sind könnten riesige mengen
an wasserstoff von ihren mutter sternen
übrig geblieben sein
dieses befindet sich in der gashülle
der super erden und könnte bei der
regulierung der temperatur eine
entscheidende rolle spielen denn
wasserstoff ist ein noch größeres
treibhausgas als kohlendioxid summen
könnte die atmosphäre solcher super
irgendwann genug für flüssige ozeane
seien sogar fernab der jupiter bahn eine
ungeheure vorstellung wenn das könnte
bedeuten dass organismen auf solchen
supererden quer durch die galaxie reisen
würden denn selbst ein einzelner planet
ohne stern könnte dann wasser bei
ausreichender hitze aufweisen und damit
die grundlage überhaupt zu leben
liefern
platz eins leben im äußeren
sonnensystem und nun lieber ich noch den
letzten wirklich spannenden hinweis
dafür dass die theorie der habitablen
zone überholt ist und zudem ein
weiteres indiz für die existenz
außerirdischen lebens denn mittlerweile
sind einige orte im äußeren
sonnensystem identifiziert an denen
biologische aktivität wahrscheinlich
ist nehmen wir mal die kleineren eis
monde des saturns cassini die raumsonde
hat entdeckt dass das innere von
enceladus einer der größten
saturnmondes nicht tiefgefroren ist
obwohl der eysmondt mit minus 190 grad
eigentlich tief gefroren sein müsste
stattdessen die überraschende
entdeckung unter der dicken eisschicht 1
37 kilometer tiefe ozean im mittel
tatsächlich zehnmal tiefer als die der
erde der grund dafür sind wohl gezeiten
effekte des saturns diese sorgen dafür
dass ein quasi fester kern in dem eis
existieren würde durchgeknetet wird und
somit im flüssigen zustand bleibt zudem
treten aus rissen in der nähe des
südpols 1000 kilometer hohe dampf
fontänen heraus ihre analyse hat
ergeben dass sie tatsächlich alle
zutaten für leben enthalten
stickstoffverbindung wie methan gut an
und pendlern und salze ein ort also im
äußeren sonnensystem an dem leben
durchaus möglich ist genauso übrigens
wie die ice monde des jupiters die
ebenso tief unter ihrem auto cad
verstecken all diese erkenntnisse machen
wieder einmal mehr als deutlich dass wir
eigentlich nichts wissen dass es noch so
unendlich viel in unserem eigenen
sonnensystem zu entdecken gibt und dass
die theorie der habitablen zone viel zu
eng gedacht ist die bausteine des lebens
können stattdessen fast überall
zusammenkommen nur der letzte kleine
schlüssel fehlt der endgültige beweis
proben von außerirdischen mikroben doch
wahrscheinlich ist das nur noch eine
frage der zeit die theorie dass das
leben auf unserer erde tatsächlich nur
durch einen einmaligen zufall entstanden
sein könnte ja die wird damit immer
unwahrscheinlicher hierbei klicks um
halte ich euch natürlich zum thema
außerirdisches leben auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr kein video dazu und auch zu
allen anderen dem verpassen wollt
dadurch mehr hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
außerirdisches leben auf dem mars neue
indizien sehr spannendes video also
nicht verpassen und draufklicken viel
spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt kann